enemies to the east enemies to the south
and arias sounded her brood of [ __ ]
mister the West Olenna the old [ __ ]
another traitor enemies to the north Ned
Stark's bastard has been named King in
the north so not murdering [ __ ] Sansa
stands beside him enemies everywhere
we're surrounded by traitors what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another Game of Thrones Season 8
discussion video I want to do something
a little different today I don't want to
present some complicated theory or
tinfoil prediction that I might have or
anything like that the purpose of
today's video is to open up a discussion
about Cersei Lannister and her chances
of making it out of this series alive
Halsey's story ends is a very popular
topic and I certainly have my own ideas
for what I think will happen to her but
I want to know what all of you think
about this from what I have seen it
seems like almost everyone assumed
Cersei will die in the end but I am
wondering how many people actually
believe she can survive the wars to come
i only communicate with the game of
thrones community through twitter and
youtube and since this platform reaches
more people than my twitter account i
figure this is the best place to ask
this question other than just posting a
poll i have seen a ton of different
theories that provide evidence for
Circe's death but i haven't seen too
many that say she will survive the
entire series according to Jamie
Lannister Cersei is going to be screwed
no matter what in the fighting in the
north is over someone wins you
understand that don't you if the dead
win they must south and kill us all
if the living win and we've betrayed
them they march south and Jaime said
that if the dead win they will come
south and kill us all and if John and
Daenerys when they will come south and
kill us all - so it seems like there is
no way out
unless Cersei decided to help them beat
the night king which we all know as of
right now Cersei has no intentions of
doing
and she seems very confident that she
can still win no matter what the numbers
she is up against you got to give it to
her
Circe's knees do not bend easily at this
point the Lannister army has to be
fairly small in comparison to the
earlier seasons
we haven't heard their exact numbers in
a while and it's not exactly clear how
many died during the field of fire but
Jamie is their commander and he knows
they are no match for the Dothraki let
alone the unsullied the north and the
Dragons Cersei does have a fleet with a
good amount of Ironborn men but they are
really only good when fighting at sea
they aren't built to fight on the land
that's not what they do
now Cersei is hiring 20,000 men from the
golden company but is that gonna be
enough
why does she seem so confident unless
she knows something that hasn't been
revealed yet 20,000 men from the golden
company is nothing to laugh at but
Daenerys has more than that would just
her death rocky numbers alone and they
were just getting warmed up when they
ambushed the lannister and Tarly
soldiers even if the golden company do
manage to make it to Westeros which I
think they will many people believe they
will break their contract with Cersei by
joining forces with the Targaryen that's
obviously not a guarantee but it's
definitely worth considering and euron
greyjoy is still a wild card - how long
will your on continue to support Cersei
if he knows he is aboard a sinking ship
Tigh CONUS Taurus from the iron bank may
have already foreshadowed a betrayal
coming from Euron the war has already
begun I've drawn first blood I
decapitated the Dornish snake my Armada
owns the Narrow Sea
Yulin Greyjoy's are moderns there's
hungry Joe is loyal to me now Cersei has
already lost her father she lost all of
her children she lost both brothers and
one of those brothers was her lover and
the commander of her army what options
would she have left if you're on cut
ties and the golden company broke their
contract with her she may be more likely
to lose the golden company than she is
you're on right now because now that
Jaime has left you're on might sees this
as an opportunity to get even closer to
Cersei now that no one will be in his
way I know the mountain will always
protect her but you know what I mean he
will no longer have a jealous lover
standing in between them
what makes this topic so interesting is
all the different scenarios that could
possibly take place as of right now it
seems like Cersei is screwed
not only does Daenerys have the dragons
but she also has the numbers but this
was also true going into season seven
remember that epic scene of Daenerys
coming across the sea with her full
force she had a massive army and fleet
behind her at that time yet Cersei still
sits on the Iron Throne at the end of
season seven that didn't seem possible
when Daenerys set sail for Westeros but
Cersei hasn't budged not only does
Cersei still sit on the Iron Throne but
Daenerys lost the Martel's
she lost the Tyrells she lost the
Greyjoy's and she lost a dragon all the
while Cersei continues to grow even more
confident even in the face of death
since the night king is already in the
north the logical thing for John and
Daenerys to do is face the night king
first he is the bigger threat he has a
bigger army a dragon and the longer he's
in the north gives him more time to
raise any dead he comes across plus
John's entire family is at Winterfell
right now in the night Kings path of
death and destruction
John Daenerys and their full force are
already heading north to deal with this
threat but there is something we
definitely have to consider what if
Daenerys loses both of her dragons in
the war against the night King what if
all of her Dothraki and unsullied are
slaughtered in the northern terrain in a
climate they have never had time to
adjust to or learn to fight in I'm not
saying that I King will win but he can
certainly do a hell of a lot of damage
to Dany and John's numbers and that
would even the odds for Cersei once
again Cersei also knows that Danny's
dragons can be killed
Cersei might not have any dragons but
she might be able to kill them if they
come south again and that's assuming the
night King doesn't kill any more first
Cersei also may have a weapon that burns
almost as hot as Dragon Fire how much
wildfire is left is still unknown but I
would like to think there is still some
more or at the very least Qyburn could
be having people work day and night to
resupply them with caches of this fiery
substance but even
with all that being said there is
another thing to keep in mind we can't
forget about Daenerys and brains vision
of the throne room this vision could be
easily forgettable if only one person
saw this in a vision but bran and
Daenerys boasts all this so it has to be
very important in terms of the endgame
there will be at least one dragon flying
over King's Landing and the city will
burn but does that mean Cersei dies does
anyone think she can make it out of this
series alive we have seen Jon Snow in
King's Landing is it possible that Jon
Snow allows Cersei to live do you think
Jon would be willing to kill Cersei if
she said she was pregnant probably not
although I think she's gonna have a
miscarriage anyway there are also a
number of different valonqar theories
out there in all of those basically
state that Cersei will die whether she
wins or loses any more battles
some say Jaime is the valonqar although
he only has one hand and some say tyrion
is the valonqar
in the books Cersei firmly believes that
Tyrion would be the one to kill her but
there is also a great theory about your
own Greyjoy being the valonqar
the only problem is in the television
show they did leave the vallencourt
prophecy out when Cersei visited Maggy
the Frog but did they leave it out
because it would be too obvious Cersei
was destined to die before the series
was over it seemed like they could have
been giving a nod to this theory when
they showed Jaime and Cersei standing on
the big map of Westeros that was painted
on the floor but there is also a chance
that it was just a weird coincidence we
also can't forget that Cersei is still
on Arya Starks hit list with Arya
straining she could easily slip behind
enemy lines and kill Cersei especially
when she can wear just about anyone's
face this is what I love about this
story and show so much when you try to
predict something you have to consider
all these different variables that can
affect the outcome of any given
storyline at any given time I have never
seen another show that had so many
different moving pieces that can result
in so many different endings it's
actually fascinating and it's what makes
these discussions so much fun there are
more than enough things to point out
that stack up against Cersei and our
odds of surviving the game of Thrones
but how many of you out there actually
think she can still be alive at the end
of all this could her survival be a part
of the bitter
we tending if there are any X factors I
left out of this video please put it
down below it because I want to take all
things into consideration also how many
of you are of the belief that Cersei
will end up as of the night's Queen in
the end I know I have heard that once or
twice but I don't think that too many
people believe that will happen but this
theory certainly picked up some steam
after that season 7 promo was released
[Music]
anyways I don't want to take up too much
more of your time I just wanted to open
up this discussion to see what everyone
thought about this specific topic put
all your thoughts questions opinions
down below in the comment section I want
to thank everyone for taking the time
out of their day to watch the video
I always appreciate that and I also want
to thank my patreon supporters I will be
doing your Q&A video next have a great
day everyone I'll see you in the next
one bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you